تداعيات زلزال السادس من فبراير ما تزال
مستمره لتظهر اثارها بشكل واضح على حكومه
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ومستقبله
السياسي موجها تحديا ايواء اكثر من مليون
ونصف المليون شخص تشردوا بعد ان تهدمت
منازلهم
وعود اطلقها اردوغان لاعاده اعمار البلاد
خلال عام الا ان الضرر طال اكثر من 160
الف مبنى منها
50000 شقه بينما يتوقع الخبراء ان تستغرق
العمليه سنوات عده وان وعود اردوغان تحولت
لتحد خلال الحمله الانتخابيه لحزبه المقبل
على الانتخابات العامه في مايو المقبل
اضرار ماديه وصلت قيمتها الى 25 مليار
دولار في تركيا بحسب بنك جي بي مورجان
الامريكي ستتحملها الحكومه التركيه
وتقديرات اخرى تشير الى اكثر من ذلك الرقم
لتكون المساعدات الدوليه التي تقدمها
الدول والبنوك والمنظمات العالميه هي
المصدر الحالي الوحيد لتمويل خطه اعاده
الاعمار
كارثه الزلزال سبقها زلزال اقتصادي اذ
يتجاوز حجم التضخم الحالي في تركيا
57% والذي يسوء وضعه بعد تعطل المعامل
والشركات وايقاف التداول في البورصه
التركيه
استطلاعات رايا تشير الى تراجع شعبيه حزب
العداله والتنميه في المناطق المنكوبه
واصوات شعبيه غاضبه تعلو اصوات الناخبين
بسبب بطء الحكومه لارسال فرق الانقاذ وعدم
الاستجابه الفوريه في بعض المناطق
يتزامن كل ذلك مع القاء اللائمه على
قوانين البناء والمقاولين والتي ساهمت
بارتفاع عدد الضحايا عمر العربيه
القضاء التركي يوسع دائره تحقيقاته بشان
حجم الدمار الذي خلفه الزلزال الذي ضرب
جنوبي البلاد خليل ابن المدينه المنكوبه
هاتاي نجم مع اسرته لكن بيته سيهدم ضمن
هذه البنايه المتصدعه رغم انها شيدت حديثا
هذا هو بيتي لا يمكنني الدخول الى البنايه
التي شيدت قبل 12 سنه فقط تضررت كثيرا
بسبب الزلزال وسيتم هدمها اذا كان هناك
تقصير من المقاولين والمشرفين على بنائها
فيجب ان يحاسبوا على ذلك اما الجد محمد
فقد استسلم للامر الواقع بيته الذي كان
مؤلفا من اربعه طوابق انهار وتسبب في مقتل
13 من افراد عائلته ابني اوكانتي وبنتي
وبنتي وبنتي
وابني وزوجتي اتوفوا اولاد اولادي اثنين
واحد 15 واحد 16
انتقلوا الى رحمه الله
يعني رقم 14 وكل شيء نظامي بس ايش صار صار
بناء نحو 200 شخص رهن الاعتقال فيما يجري
التحقيق مع مئات اخرين يشتبه بمسؤوليتهم
في انهيار الاف المباني تحت طائله ممارسات
بناء فاسده كما طالت الاعتقالات كذلك
مسؤولا بولايه غازي عنتاب تابعا للحزب
الحاكم وقد تمتد لاخرين
98% من البنايات المتضرره بنيت وفق قوانين
قديمه للبناء لا مشكله لدي اذا تمت محاسبه
كل متورط في فساد الابنيه الاخرى الجهات
الرسميه احصت الى الان تضرر اكثر من نصف
مليون منزل بشكل كامل ما يؤشر الى طول امد
التحقيقات بشانها واتساع دائرتها
كلما تقدمت اعمال رفع اطنان الانقاذ هذه
تكشفت معها حقائق جديده بشان التجاوزات
التي طالت تشييد البنايات الامر الذي فاقم
من اضرار الزلزال وخلف عشرات الالاف من
الضحايا عبد القادر خربوش العربيه